[Musique]
en ce premier week-end de vacances son
voyage dans un autre monde et dans
l'histoire avec le rang de l'épreuve des
juniors bonjour mélanie alors si vous
avez trouvé cette semaine
maintenant je vous propose qu'on
commence par les tout-petits en premier
leur à guyancourt les enfants âgés de 6
mois à 6 ans ont une mission celle de
sauver des bruits disparu une aventure à
vivre grâce aux voyages d'amélie l'armée
lit c'est une petite fille qui un matin
découvre que tous les bouts de la ville
ont été dévorés alors elle décide de
partir à la chasse dans cette expo tout
est permis ou presque on va parler on
peut toucher et surtout on peut écouter
et victoire la créatrice nous en dire
quelques mots c'est un moyen bien sûr de
leur permettre d'être à l'écouté de
faire attention un petit peu ce qui se
passe autour d'eux et ben là d'une
manière plus sensible de regarder
d'écouter de voir de toucher et de vivre
une expérience sensorielle
c'est un camaïeu de tissus de couleurs
qu'on peut trouver dans le ciel avec des
textures différentes
donc là on est sur le toucher un petit
peu plus loin on a aussi des galets sur
la plage donc là l'idée c'est
d'apprendre quelques notions de rythme
alors pour les aventuriers il faut pas
traîner avant qu amélie par te demander
de l'aide à d'autres enfants puisque
l'exposition est à découvrir à la maison
de quartier auguste renoir jusqu'au
samedi 7 juillet et pour les plus grands
alors comme pour les plus grands la ont
fait un bond dans l'histoire ça vous dit
camille wiiu pas trop loin quand même
alors là on va partir sur une activité
qui s'appelle ça s'appelle mon
patrimoine c'est un dispositif s'adresse
aux jeunes âgés de 6 à 18 ans alors pour
2017 ce sera qui avait plus de 210 sites
français qui accueillait des jeunes dans
les yvelines
plusieurs sites sont concernés pour
royal des champs à magny les hameaux la
maison elsa triolet luz aragon qu'on
voit l'image à cet ascète hindou ennuis
et la bergerie nationale de rambouillet
alors pour cette dernière pour les
vacances d'été les enfants vont devenir
des bénévoles sur un chantier de
restauration 12 d'entre eux vont
découvrir les techniques d'antan pour
réparer les dégradations
c'est l'association rempart qui sont
occupées coûté ni fait maçonnerie taille
de pierre ce dont on a besoin pour
restaurer le site sur lequel on est les
savoir faire anciens notamment parce que
en maçonnerie traditionnelle on va pas
leur apprendre à monter du parpaing on
va plutôt leur apprendre à remettre des
moellons dans un mur avec du mortier à
la chaux donc voilà c'est vraiment les
savoir faire anciens c'est important
aussi cette question de transmission qui
sachent qu'il ya différents types de
maçonnerie qu'on ne restera pas pareil
qu'on construit une maison aujourd'hui
alors remparts a aussi eu de chantier
cet été pour les adolescents un petit
coup d'oeil sur leur site
et c'est mon patrimoine c'est aussi de
l'archéologie de l'écriture de la
réalisation vidéo ya tout un tas de
projets tous les rendez-vous sont
disponibles sur le site qui s'affiche en
bas de l'écran